des hommes armés ont pris d'assaut des
installations gazières
deux canadiens ont pris part à ce
carnage attribué à une branche d'al
qaida nouvelles de dernière heure un peu
la grc annoncé la plus tard cet après
midi qu'il a déjoué un complot pour
commettre un attentat terroriste
en australie il n'a aucun avis est très
facile pour des gens de s'abreuver à ces
sources le radicalisme news à québec
je peux vous confirmer que les deux
personnes qui ont été happés par le
véhicule est à 10000 talent
le gouvernement n'a surpris plusieurs en
évoquant une possible attaque terroriste
il était même considéré comme étant
suspect terroristes parmi les plus
surveillés au pays
oh
j'ai mis mes chers compatriotes une
attaque
vautard et violent une urne en
territoire
étudia d'une violence extrême a tué 12
personnes mises en taille et la
démocratie aujourd'hui fut réclame
indien et canadiennes se tient aux côtés
du peuple de la france pendant leur cap
et le donation